for those writers that do believe in and
plot when it comes to plot how can a
writer figure out what isn't working
for uh um it's
I think that's in later rewrites
throw it all in there and then um
and then and what I what I do is I is uh
after I I outline more after than I do
before so then I outline the scenes and
I kind of I was I want the I want the
scenes to uh
you know I kind of think of it as a DJ
so you know the the
the heavy conflict here is a nine and
then let's get it back down to a four
then let's bring it up to a seven as you
know it's uh I used to DJ at bars and
stuff too in San Francisco with my
crates of vinyl I want to keep the Dance
Floor going so how do I keep the Dance
Floor going I can't you know smash cut
you know uh you know uh I'm blanking on
Fiona Apple to AC DC I probably can but
but how does how do they stay on the
dance floor so then they go buy more
drinks so I get more money at the end of
the night from the place
um so I think it's just about it's about
curating the scenes and then
um
and and just with and and also the scene
has to make as you get towards your
final draft
the scene has to make a case for itself
is this does the scene even make it into
the movie
and it and I find it really intriguing
that
this yes it makes it into the movie Yes
it gets shot yes it gets into post and
even those scenes get cut and
um and so
the there's there's a reason those
scenes are written even if we have to
take them out when we're in the
screenwriting process there's a reason
those scenes are filmed even if they
have to be taken out during
post-production and I don't know what
that reason is and there's probably
producers going we're losing money and
when you do this but at the same time
those actors have to the actor and
director have to work through that scene
that never makes it into the movie but
that may inform how another scene is
shot or how a character actor comes at
uh their angle on another scene and for
some I I feel like there's no um
they're they're you know there's a lot
on the there's a there's a lot of pages
that you wrinkle up and throw away and
you're just like that didn't work but
you need it to get to where it works you
need it you need those and you need to
embrace those pages and you need and
just go wow yeah you almost have to say
thank you to the bad writing because the
bad writing gets you to the good stuff
would you play Closing Time at the end
of your DJ sets I yeah the last I mean I
haven't DJ'd in so many years but the
the last ones I did um
was uh I'd throw on a Frank Sinatra or
Tom Jones oh wow after you know after
I've kept the whole Dance Floor going
and it's just kind of like now we're
mellowing out you know we're bringing it
down okay so yes the bartenders are
trying to do all their work to clean up
and it's the last call Ding last call
I'm just like
so in a movie though you're also you're
you're winding down the audience whether
it's a yes wind down or or a sad one or
in some foreign film sort of an
ambiguous ending where we don't really
know right when it comes to plot and
then the wind down happens and we're a
few minutes from the end
um is there really a bad ending is there
an ending that
this is not textbook how it should have
been you know if if it's a happy story
sad whatever yeah it's I think um
I'm trying to there's there's a film I
just watched where I was like oh that
ending was so horrible I can't remember
what film it was darn it and it was a
good film
um there's a lot of films I really love
and I'm like oh you blew in the ending
um and uh
but as far as like as far as the stakes
of act three and the stakes of the high
tension and then we need the brat we all
need to sit in it we all kind of need to
sit and relax and go
wow and we have to do that with the
characters on the screen and with
everyone there's a there's a movie that
I bring to class especially my beginning
classes I make everyone and I've watched
this hundreds of times because I make
everyone completely dissect every single
scene in it it's Little Miss Sunshine
and and Little Miss Sunshine I I
actually have the I get the DVDs in the
movies because I don't like you know so
I'm the DVD collector but they also have
the extras on there and they have the
deleted scenes and there was like one or
two extra scenes at the end of the movie
that they completely shot
um where there was like where they're
like well that was crazy they're they're
another like an a rest stop and they're
all on a bench and they're all talking
everything's just gone great and said oh
what do you want a hamburger and they
shot this whole scene but the end of the
movie is the bus driving away and
you know it's the some people sometimes
you don't know what the end of the movie
is until it's way in post-production uh
and and they didn't know they thought
they needed these tagons they there's
there's a lot of times where
um filmmakers feel like they need to uh
to hold the hand of the audience a
little more and the audience can hold
their own handle a lot of times the
audience can get it uh we don't have to
um
we don't have to uh kind of push it on
them now feel like this it's just like
no stop
that that was good enough
you're fine uh take a breath and think
about that
I like that is do you think that just
only comes from seeing the actors play
out that scene that it's hard to tell on
the page
um
I don't know if it's hard yeah it could
be hard to tell on the page and
we're just trying to write the best
story we can with
um it's funny so with Confessions of a
Teenage Jesus jerk I was
from the final draft I was very adamant
about the ending
um and I was like this is the ending
this is it and uh and there was a scene
that was
um asked to for afterwards and I'm just
like
no I didn't want to write it and I and
it had to be written and then they shot
it and then it didn't make the film it
didn't make the final cut and for some
odd reason maybe it did need to be shot
so maybe you know maybe I I've done so
many things wrong and my Approach has
been you know sometimes my Approach
isn't the greatest approach sometimes I
could be a little friendlier and a
little more amicable and go oh you're
right let's just do that and see what
happens
um but with this I was so
sure that that was the end but the the
people involved weren't sure and it's
okay that they're not sure and so just
let people not be sure and then
you know pray and post that it all works
out and and it may have been that you
know depending on how the tone of the
film went because when that edit when
it's in the editing room it's being the
whole story is being told Again by an
editor so
um they may have needed to get that on
camera just in case they kept different
scenes in there or they had to lose
scenes and but to get the whole tone of
the film they went nope that was the
ending
um so
there's
there's so many elements to how to end a
movie I mean I guess there it's and so
much of that stake so on the page the
best you can do and then does it end up
in the Final Cut who knows
um because there's so many
uh you know there's so many factors
involved so so that's interesting you
you resisted sort of the suggested
ending they wanted an extra scene at the
end and then it ended up not happening
and you ended up agreeing that that was
actually a good thing to have that extra
scene no no they shot the scene and and
then but but I won and then I won
because they that scene Hit The Cutting
Room floor so the movie ended exactly as
I wanted it to end
does that make sense yeah and I wasn't
sure if you wanted The Cutting Room
floor one you actually agreed with them
oh okay no no I still I did I still
didn't agree and when I when I was sent
the rough cut as I was coming to the end
um I was going yeah the I had a I had to
cut to Black it was cut to Black I'm
like cut to Black cut to Black got the
black and a boom cut to Black and I was
like yes so um it was uh
you know and there were and there were
other battles that I had where I was
like okay this is right and you don't go
and then and I was totally wrong and so
it's it there's that's the beauty of the
the collaboration of um have those
disagreements
um because as the writer you know oh
yeah I can like pretend like I know
everything but I don't once you what's
your once you're on set what you're with
a director once you're seeing actors
it's it's you you really got to kind of
let things go and uh yeah the only thing
I was so I was really adamant about was
how the how it was going to end and I
just I saw that from the beginning and
um and it wasn't it didn't make
anyone feel comfortable so maybe
everyone needed to feel comfortable and
then they went no wait that's right the
ending is
um the cut to Black